in one of your fqxi talks you mentioned
that some of the most profound results
in philosophy come from algorithmic
information theory yeah and
coincidentally i'll be speaking to
gregory chaitan in a few weeks
so okay
please explain to me why you think that
okay i can use one of um
greg
chayton i mean he does insist that be
pronounced chaitin rather than shaytan
um
he's a very interesting fellow in many
ways and he's done some great work one
of his
results in fact i think does have this
character to it he's got an
impossibility theorem
which is um basically it says that there
is
a integer
l
such that we can never ever prove
that any particular
[Music]
computation
that we would want to do any particular
string has komagal complexity greater
than l
okay there is some such integer and
he actually has an estimate of it as i
believe based upon this programs of
being 4 000 if you're using lisp as your
turing machine
um
but think about what that means
there's going to be this number like ml
which is like say 4 000 that's saying
that you know anything that's longer
than 4 000 bytes
um so you cannot prove that the komodo
complexity of any particular string
is going to be greater than 4000 bytes
we know
that there's a very finite number of
strings that have less than 4000 bytes
at most depending on the grammar and
syntax of your
language and so on it'll be two to the
four thousand which would be a big
number but
i'm not it's very very finite
so that means that there's an infinite
number of strings
that exist
whose commodore complexity
we can never actually determine
so we can never know what is the
simplest program
size
for determining the simplest program
for actually doing those calculations
it's amazing restriction on what we
human beings can do
to give you another example this is one
that i know best from my a book by um
lee and vitani it's kind of like the
bible and these turing machine things
you can actually
prove the existence of a function
from the integers to the integers
which is always increasing it never it
never sometimes will stay the same but
it never goes down and eventually gets
to infinity
such that every function you can
possibly compute no matter how you do it
that is also always increasing and gets
to infinity
will be strictly greater than this
you wouldn't have even thought there is
such a limitation that could even make
sense
do whatever you want say okay here's a
function which
it has the value one
for the first million numbers from one
through a million it's got the value one
then it's got the value two but that's
for the next million to the millions
okay
you know make it be whatever you want
every rule that you can put down for how
to construct this
it's going to actually be getting to
infinity faster than this other function
which is a very strange thing and it's
reality
it's one of the most fundamental
philosophical results in the sense that
philosophy
should not be biased towards what we
human beings consider
to be compelling i find it that
impossibility results in general
and of these sorts in particular
they are very deep philosophy whether or
not we even appreciate they had meaning
before we came across them